welcome to the couples debate pop
culture we've hit significant others
against each other in head-to-head
competition they'll be debating which
pop culture phenomenon is bigger our
first topic is Fitness which is bigger
the dad bod or the six-pack the dad bod
is our generations way of breaking down
the stereotypes that we've been given by
our parents as for what is attractive
I'm gonna give you points for that hard
work should never go unrecognized the
six-pack with her on a man or woman
really shows the commitment that people
can put into loving their own bodies dad
vodkas a stronger commitment to a
relationship as opposed to a set of
weights you know there could be people
out there who are in a committed
relationship and they go to the gym
together
jewel is a sacred space I like to be
alone damn you've made me love my belly
dad bought tryouts today our next topic
is hair which is bigger the fauxhawk or
the mandible I think the man bun will be
looked upon as the mullet of our
generation and could define millennial
culture as a whole the mullet is quite
big the faux hawk works for more people
it's been around since the 2000
objection did I or did I not have a man
bun when you met me and did you know of
my man bun oh I think this debate is
over man bun wins our next topic is
dating which is bigger dating apps or
group dating the future is here and it's
swiping lift while on the toilet and
finding your future partner group dates
are something that is as old as time
how long are we really going to be using
the Internet who wants to go out who
wants to get dressed up 67.8% of your
time is spent at home what better way to
spend that time than finding the love of
your life 92% of the time people are out
of their homes and only 76% of the time
are they in their home there is a lot of
fuzzy math here on both sides but I'm a
real sucker for made-up statistics you
both win and for our last topic of
debate the Taco Bell case a lupa versus
the Taco Bell case a lupa is that right
this is bigger than selfies bigger than
brunch weight bigger than the internet
no you have it
I guess the Taco Bell taesoo was bigger
than everything we could get one of
those for me to look for the program's
over we get one more of those
hey bring the house lights back up we're
not done excuse me why are you leaving
why are you doing this to me not big
enough to share